the question is do i make them myself
and the answer is
oh
yes
ow that's the result of doing glass
blowing by an amateur somebody who's a
physicist doing glassblowing the answer
is i make the first klein bottle i make
sort of number one i work on the design
figuring out how the spline should look
then i work with adams and chittenden
who are real glass blowers over here in
berkeley and so they bend it put a glass
lathe and and do cool things like like
you start with pyrex
you torch it up heat it up
blow on it
and inflate it until you get something
that looks like ah
looks like this
and after you inflate it on the torch oh
man i wish i had a glass lathe here you
could so you could see hot glass trust
me it's hot um red hot glass and then
after you inflate it
you take a diamond saw cut here torch of
the base open
then you make a
then you go to the glass lathe
take another half inch piece of pyrex
tubing flare one end bend it cut it
put in the glass lathe weld it
like this
that's even visible so okay so you weld
it in like this and you get
this is even noticeable
far out
and you get
a torched in
piece like this
next step is
cut here
pop open this hole
then go bend a piece a goose neck like
this
and notice how you have to seal one end
and
keep this pressurized as you bend it or
else it'll kink around here
cut here cut here
weld it right there
bend it around like this
and there's your klein bottle
oh oh and along the way you drop it on
the floor it breaks it shatters you pick
up everything you burn yourself you know
the usual
you know it's glass blowing it's hot
glass
surface
and compare it with any other klein
bottle then this one has the lowest
possible energy
i thought that is pretty cool maybe that
is number four
but again you can obviously tell by
looking at it that this thing seems to
have some chirality again